october is breast cancer awareness month
and early detection is key hope cancer
care of nevada explains the importance
of self-exams warning signs and the
advances that have been made to fight
breast cancer
[Music]
we are here at hope cancer care of
nevada with the founder and board
certified medical oncologist dr raja
mehdi dr mehdi thank you so much for
talking to us today and as you know
october is breast cancer awareness month
and what are some of the clinical
features and the risk factors for breast
cancer just to put things into
perspective about 275 000 women will be
diagnosed uh
you know on an annual basis with breast
cancer
so about one in eight women will will
see it in their lifetime so it's
extremely important to continue to make
improvements in our outcomes decrease
the mortality and awareness is the key
on the self
exam some of the things that you can
watch for is a lump in the breast or it
could just be a change in the skin of
the breast or a nipple discharge
sometimes
uh women don't feel a lump in the breast
but it's under the arm
so that those are the lymph nodes that
sometimes are swollen without a palpable
mass in the breast that can happen too
just
in the
last 10 years or so
the there's been about 10 percent
reduction in mortality
due to the advancements in screening and
treatments there are many different
treatment options for breast cancer can
you tell us some of those our
momentarium
in fighting
breast cancer has increased to almost a
third of the drugs now
are non-chemotherapy
so
targeted therapies essentially will find
a
target on the surface of the cell
and then they will go attach and either
let our own immune system fight it
or sometimes we can attach the
conventional chemotherapy in a very low
dose
to that target that will deliver it
inside the cell
what age do you suggest that women get
in and start to start taking these
measures getting a mammogram certainly
so the american cancer society at this
time
women starting as early as 40 are
eligible to get mammograms now whatever
the therapy it can be intense when
you're fighting cancer how does hope
cancer center
really try to provide that support to
people during that journey
so first is the the whole personal touch
knowing the patient and the families i
think that's where it starts and then we
have a dedicated team of professionals
to back it up through the treatment if
someone is not doing well
they
have the capability of bringing them in
as a same-day appointment everybody
who's an active treatment
instead of waiting and going to the
hospital they can be brought in and our
team is always ready for them
hope cancer care of nevada has two
locations one here in vegas and one in
pahrump for more information call the
numbers on your screen or visit
hccnevada.com
we'll be right back